بعد اسيل من انتقد اشتياق قدمت وزيره
ودفاع الالمانيه كريستينا الابراخت
استقالتها من منصبها استقاله تتزامل معها
قد اجتماع للحلفاء الغربيين معلومات
المتحده في قاعده رمشتاين الامريكيه في
المانيا
ومساعدات الجديده لاوكرانيا بهذه المناسبه
في حين تنوي المانيا استثمار 100 مليون
100 مليار يورو لتحديث جيشها وتخضع لضغوط
لتسليم اوكرانيا
اثاره انتقادات مع سلطات من السلطات
الاوكرانيه باعلامها ارسال الاف الخوه في
مكان الرئيسكي يطالب باسعه الثقيله
للمزيد ما في الاستوديو زميلنا خالد
الغراب لاهلا بك خالد ربما سؤال الذي يطر
حل من تاثير الاستقاله الوزير الالمانيه
على الاستراتيجيه العسكريه لمواجهه الغزو
الروسي في المرحله المقبله
التاثير قد يكون ايجابي اذا احسن المستشار
شولسي اختيار البديل الوزير الجديد لماذا
لن يكون هناك تاثير اولا لانها المانيا لم
تخسر يعني شخصيه عسكريه فازه لها رؤيه
عسكريه لتطوير استراتيجيه البلاد الامنيه
ولها من الشخصيه ما يحاول ان يقنع
المستشار بهذه التغيرات هذه السيده
الوزيره التقدمت في العزيز العديد من
المرات في البدايه عندما اعلنت تقديم 5000
خوذه عسكريه للاوكرانين حتى انهم اصبحوا
يسخرون ويتسالون متى ستصل الوسائد
بعدها انتقدت لانها اصطحبت ابنها في
مروحيه عسكريه وقامت بالتقاط صوره له وهو
وضعها بعد ذلك على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي واخيرا وهي تهنئ
العامه الجديد وكانت تتحدث عن حرب مستعره
في قلب اوروبا لكن من يشاهد المشهد ويسمع
يسمع الاحتفالات بالبدايه العام الجديد كل
هذه تبين تعطي لمحه عن شخصيه ربما لا تعي
تماما بحجم المسؤوليات العسكريه التي هي
هذا بالنسبه للشكل لكن هذا يعكس المضمون
والمضمون الاهم الخطه الاستراتيجيه التي
اعلنت عندما غيرت المانيا من عقليتها
الاستراتيجيه الامنيه بانها قالت سنعزز
قدراتنا العسكريه ب 100 مليار يورو من
المفترض من يحمل هذا المشروع هي وزيره
الدفاع لكن مصادر نقلت ان شولتس وامام
الطباطؤ في التعاطي مع هذا الملف اصبح هو
يهتم ببعض جزئيات في هذا الم وكلف اخرين
لكي يتولوا هذا الموضوع اذا
الوزير التي تغيب ليست بالوزيره التي يمكن
ان يكون لها تاثير حقيقي لا في الامور
العسكريه الخاصه ببلادنا ولا في
الاستراتيجيه همم استراتيجيه التحالف
مواجهه روسيا لكن حتى نكون عدرين
المسؤوليه لا تقع على على عليها واحده لان
من اختار الوزيره ومن سمح لها بالبقاء في
هذا المنصب رغم كل هذه الانتقادات ومن بدا
كانه يغطي ربما حتى بعض الاخطاء هونتس ومن
بدا كم يعني المسؤول عن همم سوره المانيا
المتردده في كيفيه التعامل عسكريا مع ال-
ال- المطالبات المتكرره بان تقدم اسلحه
حديثه للاوكرانيين هو المستشار وليس
الوزير الوزير تنفذ ما يريد المستشار اذا
همم هناك جزء من مسؤوليه في دوره المانيا
اسف في في هذا التحالف يتعلق بالمستشار
وهو موجود وهو الذي اختار الوزير الجديد
ويحدد له مكانه في تحديد الاستراتيجيه في
التعامل مع هذا الموضوع وفي النهايه امن
يحدد كل استراتيجيه التحالف ليس المانيا
وانما الولايات المتحده
الولايات المتحده هي التي الان تجري
تدريبات او تشرف على تدريبات على الارض
الالمانيه تدريبات تشارك فيها قوات مشاه
ومدرعات ومدافع استعدادا لمعركه الربيع من
يحضر ويشرف على هذه المناورات هو رئيس
الاركان الامريكي وليس مسؤول المانيا رغم
انها تتم على ارض المانيا والمانيا عندما
همم تجيب عن المطالبات بتقديم الدبابه
القتال واحده من اهم القتال في العالم
اثنان تقول نحن مستعدون للموافقه على
تقديم مثل هذه الدبابه لاوكرانيا لكن لم
تظهر ان انت تاتي الموافقه جماعيه من
التحالف من حلف الاطلسي لماذا لانها تخشى
رده فعل الروسيه ومن يعطي مثل هذه
الموافقه المسؤول الاول في حلف الاطلس هي
هي الولايات المتحده وبالتالي حتى المانيا
عندما تريد ان تفعل خطوه بهذه الاهميه
تنتظر الضوء الاخضر من الولايات المتحده
لكي يكون لها تاثير وهذا يحدد ويوضح الى
ايمن محدوديه الدوري الالماني في هذا التح
شكرا جزيلا لك يا خالد